gore's you oh come on don't act like you
never tried it okay so this huh I wanna
I want to revisit Harry Potter but in a
more fun way less critical fashion than
I have the first well last most of times
that I've talked about the franchise on
here cuz the thing is I actually really
enjoy Harry Potter I enjoyed the world I
enjoyed those characters I enjoy those
books I enjoyed the first eight movies
to varying degrees and I don't love the
fact that since I've started talking
about Harry Potter around here all I've
really had to talk about is stuff that I
haven't liked much so let's just have a
bit of fun silly goofy vaguely
inappropriate fun so Hogwarts is a
school and schools of course have
curriculums now schools in theory are
supposed to do more than simply teach
academics they are supposed to in fact
prepare kids for the world beyond the
walls of the school and Hogwarts does
seem poor at its best when it's not
being run by Umbridge does appear to try
and do that with its various classes you
know there's the practical stuff like
potions and herbology but there's also
things that may are less likely to go to
a direct career like defense against the
dark dark arts yes maybe some people
will want to be an Auror but like plenty
just that's good basics to know now it's
been noted before that there are a lot
of what would to us muggles be very
necessary stuff like say math but that
don't appear to be part of the
curriculum
but there's one thing that I remember as
part of my education that I not only
wonder is it part
the Hogwarts curriculum I want to know
how is it different and that's sex ed
because I got some questions about how
some of this works in the Wizarding
World and I'll just go through various
elements
you know based off my own memory of sex
education the sorts of things that I
would think would be covered or just
like might come up in the course of
these kinds of conversations if you're
trying to relay me especially if you're
trying to relay the information to
students so some of these questions are
like I'm about like what will be on the
curriculum but others just people is a
heck of a lot of sex questions about
about the Harry Potter world okay
that's a lot of preamble for this
premise let's get going
first question birth control now we know
that wizards and witches don't make use
of muggle medicine so birth control by
pill or even really prophylactic
probably not in the cards so are their
birth control charms do since they could
theoretically be cast either on a
woman's womb or a guy could like cast
some sort of temporary sterility on his
sperm is there is there the same sort of
societal expectation that women that
birth control is a woman's thing to be
responsible for is that the same
eliciting Society says theoretically if
they're using magic either gender should
be equally as capable of making use of
those kinds of charms on themselves i if
it's charms and if it's things like that
can they be countered if they are and
it's done so without the knowledge of
the person whose birth control spell you
encountered is that a sex cry if birth
control fails what are the remedies on
that I don't really want to dive down
the rabbit hole of this but I'm just
gonna toss that out there is magical
or at the very least you know magical
morning-after pill oh I got a wonder
but of course pregnancy is not the only
concern when you are dealing with
teenagers with raging hormones which
Hogwarts has in spades there's also the
wonderful world of sexually transmitted
diseases oh boy
now I did actually do something I also
rarely do hmm
I did a tiny bit of research so I was
wondering what is the deal with sort of
disease and that sort of thing in the
Wizarding World I figured there had to
be something there but I didn't want to
make assumptions so I actually looked up
what
JK Rowling herself said on Pottermore
and I'm gonna quote you so what she said
was broadly speaking wizards have the
power to correct or override quote
mundane nature but not magical nature
therefore a wizard could catch anything
a mother might catch but he could cure
all of it he would also comfortably
survive a scorpion sting that might kill
a muggle whereas he might die if bitten
by a venomous tend to Kula hmm so
basically what that means is if it
originates from the Wizarding World
whether that be through an actual spell
or simple or a magical creature or
you're just some sort of disease that
and she does side examples of diseases
that are unique to the Wizarding World
like dragon pox so they do exist and
those sorts of diseases don't have
instantaneous magical cures it's why
mad-eye moody had to have a granted
there was still magic in it but had to
have a prosthetic eye and he couldn't
just magic himself a new eye so they're
not gonna have our sexually transmitted
diseases but what kind of weird bizarre
magic STDs are they gonna have like is
there an STD that makes your genitals
detached not like in a leprosy brought
it off way but just like just attach and
go off wander off
do their own thing like what what sort
of stuff do you gotta watch out for what
is the wizard clap like that's kind of
what I'm wondering here and I don't know
all right
next I've got to bring up something that
kind of relates to the birth control
since I started there um interspecies
sexual relationships we know they happen
because we have characters like Hagrid
who is half giant and nobody seems to
make a deal of that I mean people pick
on Hagrid but they pick on hybrid cuz
they think he's dumb not because they're
like picking on his heritage not even to
the extent that like they do with mobile
burns or mud blows so it does seem that
you know maybe insofar as they would be
considered a form of mudblood or maybe
Hagrid even isn't because I mean a giant
is still part of the magical world so
maybe it's not even as bad so it does
seem like interspecies relationship or
at least humanoid interspecies
relationships are not that frowned upon
or at least an odd not a huge deal is
made of them so some questions about
that which species are capable of
actually producing offspring so we know
Giants and humans what if a human had
intercourse with a goblin or a troll I
don't think you'd want to but
theoretically even though I think it's
safe to assume that humanoid
interspecies couples are acceptable we
still don't see any so is it still kind
of thought of as weird is there a limit
because given what is or isn't sentient
in the Harry Potter universe like is a
centaur too far away from being human do
ghosts have ongoing relationships with
wizards like I I'm really curious as to
both the mechanical logistics and
societal acceptance of those kinds of
relationships so and then there's some
of the specific things that we know
exist within the Wizarding World that
you stop and think about it
bring up a lot of questions when applied
to sex so take for instance the animagus
the wizards and witches who can become a
certain animal even though humanoid
interspecies relationships appear to be
acceptable
is it okay for a wizard while in an
animal form an animagus in animal form
to have a sexual relationship with that
species of animal is that considered
best eality is that a crime is that okay
can an animagus while an animal form
become impregnated by that breed of
animal if even if they can't if it is an
animagus who is already pregnant if when
they transform into an anime is does
that when they transform into their
animal does that change the fetus into
the animal as well and for a male
animagus while an animators form does
that go down to the DNA level of their
sperm does their ejaculate while in an
animal form is that gonna basically mean
they would impregnate someone with an
animal or with another wizard I don't
know I think things could get
potentially more than a little freaky
which event brings us to what about the
kink
community I mean I would imagine even if
sex standards and what is or isn't
normal is probably quite different for
wizards and witches
I mean kinks a thing people are kinky I
mean some of the stuff I'm talking about
with the animagus probably falls under
that but here's a question for you given
what we know about BDSM and bondage and
punishment and those sorts of consensual
but physically taxing relationships is
the casting of an unforgivable curse
like the Cruciatus curse still a crime
if
it is cast on someone consensually as
part of BDSM play because what we know
about the unforgivable curses basically
is you cast this that that is a crime so
is that truly regardless of
circumstances are there underground
BDSM wizard clubs where that kind of
stuff is done you know in private I
would imagine something that's probably
a huge hit in especially if there's any
kind of underground use of it but I
would think in sexual play in general
would be Polyjuice potion Polyjuice
potion brings up a lot of possibilities
I mean first thing up atop my head I
would imagine it would be incredibly
popular to enhance say roleplay
scenarios for those who want to have
that little extra thrill of acting of
pretending like they're with someone
other than their normal partner while
still actually technically being with
their normal partner but then we sort of
come back to the question that I asked
about some other stuff is it a sex crime
because in this case if you use
Polyjuice potion to impersonate someone
and then as that person you get consent
from someone else for sexual activity
but they think you're not who you are
with in the Wizarding World is that a
crime now to be clear be any equivalent
of that in the muggle world is
considered a crime because someone can't
give informed consent if they have been
deliberately deceived
dude the sex crime law work the same way
in the Wizarding World because yeah I
would imagine that you would potentially
be a really big problem especially if
it's not properly personal prosecuted
also coming back to the kink really we
also know because of what happened to
Hermione when she accidentally ended up
with cat hair instead of the hair of the
person who's trying to impersonate you
can end up with human kind of animal as
hybrids so basically furries can be a
real thing in the Harry Potter world
because of Polyjuice potion I even when
I was driving got my notes that one
hadn't occurred to me yet oh man this is
a rabbit hole oh god that's a [ __ ]
we'll turn of words for what I just say
come out ah okay okay let's let's wrap
it up on the last thing that at least I
have notes on love potions what the
actual legality of love potions we know
that they are dangerous and there seems
to be an acknowledgment of them as being
dangerous but at the same time they know
how to make them they talked about them
in school how illegal are they I mean is
just the use of a love potion in and of
itself is that a crime
shouldn't it be I mean especially if
something like the Imperius curse to
override someone's free will and control
them if that's an automatic crime should
a potion that forces someone's
affections in the direction they might
otherwise not being claimed
automatically be a crime regardless of
what you sort of manipulate that person
to do because of the love shouldn't that
initial thing just be a crime and in
which case why don't they teach you
there why did we give this much
information on love potions I mean
granted I can't definitely on the movies
I don't think I can remember the books
if they were actually taught how to mix
any love potions but at the very least
they they do have accesses and the
information on how to make them because
there are some who try and spike Harry
stuff with that in the sixth book and
movie so even if they're not flat-out
being taught they have access to the
materials and the know-how and how to
make them so that goes beyond just like
an equivalent of say a drug education
where you weren't kids about roofies
this is saying here's the chemical
components of roofies everything you
need to make it is in this book oh and
the supplies are in that closet over
there I just have so many questions none
of which I ever expect to get answered
because yeah I wouldn't expect you to
ever address my weird brain you folks
get to hear about it you're welcome my
thoughts on sex and the Wizarding World
Harry Potter apropos of nothing except
my own bizarre thought processing yes
what do you think about all this that I
have just thrown at you to try and
digest have you had these thoughts
before have I just destroyed your
childhood whatever your thoughts are
drop them down in the comments let's
talk about it whole bunch of stuff to do
buttons links the patreon is down there
my P o box is down there I've got my
Amazon wishlist up in videos that are up
this month because it is my birthday
otherwise it's not normally there but
you know hi I appreciate it
posters all the links to check out
besides give a look at what's down there
or you know what don't if you don't want
to it's okay because at the end of the
day you're the counselled I'm just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]